yes hello and welcome to this rabbit
game on leeches let's get before going
in some again gets around 84 no
particular information about the wrong
yeah I've changed them search and love
it for this game doing a search for game
with the middle minimum rating will loop
minimum rating of 2004 the opponent had
some feedback on the rapid games and
there were some comments that I should
up them rating level a little bit yeah I
started out with a minimum rating of
1800 and down maybe that was at a too
low I mean it's something you can argue
about what kind of minimum rating is
good
I want the games to be competitive but I
also want to give people the opportunity
to play me at least once in a while so
I've opted for the moment but I will
call we also do the odd game with a
lower minimum rating so this is the do I
have water I have water yeah that's good
and this is a full half defense and whoa
what is we are doing here community 5
hmm well play low what do you do against
us cannibals um if I trade it's going to
be entirely symmetrical there that
cannot be all that great if a trade on
d5 look like Quincy - there's Bishop to
f5 that doesn't make any sense
Queen c2 is also Bishop f5 so yep
probably e3 is the move that at the end
comes to mind 25 while not the move
you'll expect but doesn't seem to be all
that bad
Queen a4 is also an option just get out
of the trade and play Knight c3 with the
tempo next even though you can argue
that the Queen isn't fantastically
placed down let's do it I mean III is an
alternative but it's a little bit lame
to allow the Queen trade now my idea is
just 93 with the temple and ultimately
try to play each form one of the ideas
of these early like Queen b3 here or
Queen c2 is that you get this position
with the dnc pond traders which in
general is kind of favorable for white
and white has an extra center Ponyo is
to get this kind of situation without
the pawn 84 in the mainline Slav you
open up a four plate and the same kind
of structure where the wicked be
Foursquare as a source for counter play
so if I get some time on the greed and I
can play you form I'm really quite happy
still this is a very solid position for
black gal you cannot get something super
great hour this problem but maybe a
slight advantage I can get yeah this is
certainly an idea and simply saying okay
I'm weakening my structure but I'm going
to win time on the Queen yeah at least I
now have an easy move Queen c2 Bishop f5
looks kind of pointless in Queen b3
I mean creepy three wouldn't be that
terrible because the Queen trade
arguably isn't all that
great huh interesting stuff
it just goes e6 so if I play 93 is going
to go Bishop before I guess and then
simply trade off yeah but this is
certainly good for white I was thinking
a little bit because you can argue that
a3 is an option to get negative three
with the full tempo coming without any
Bishop before ideas yeah so if he goes
Bishop before here that's an interesting
question if I should immediately force
the capture with Bishop d2 then it
basically has to take on c3 sometimes
wonder if this is the right kind of
setup actually maybe I should do it like
this
it looks a little bit better right okay
so he went back to the 8th let's not all
that bad
okay but okay I want to play you for if
I do that now is going to play B form
and that doesn't work really I mean I
can go in five she takes on c3 I take on
f6 but this kind of thing doesn't really
feel fantastic
okay so a3 is going to play a six a four
and mc5 it is kind of working and maybe
they maybe just develop stuff I mean I
don't have to play in form you have to
see that if I can play something with
them good which is preventing him from
playing c5 I should be okay
I wonder ever should actually capture
now to make him take with the bishop
instead of annoyed now it's not clear
that this is all that great I don't want
to play with you fall in this position
probably okay so this should be three
warm you can also take
hmm I don't know if it should be 3 is
right
probably yes it's a potential tempo on
h7 like table f6 Queen c2 is a temple
okay so I need to try to prevent the the
c5 push going on a 4 here a Form B form
Bishop f6 point X III Bishop e7
it looks kind of good Jim so let's try a
form a four makes it more difficult for
him to play c5 as I have the pressure on
their pawn
we are still should've taken s6 first
okay
the I expect them to take with the
bishop even though you might make an
argument for pawn takes like pawn takes
Knight e4 f5 that's maybe in maybe an
option
taking on c3 I'll take is 7 that doesn't
lead to anything good
yeah maybe pawn takes that can actually
be a good move just emphasizing the
central control over g5 a d5 and keeping
the bishop on your 7 so that it helps to
support c5 if I manage in this position
to prevent him from playing c6 to c5 the
position is strategically extremely
favorable for white so he has to get
this in absolutely yeah probably be
takes sorry GT xf 6 is a good move
yeah blue team
he takes them to no while it is quite
plenty a key decision even though if you
look at Bishop f6 I play 94 and in
comparison I think the porn capture
looks far more attractive I think I
would play G takes f6 quite quite
quickly to be honest maybe I am
evaluating it incorrectly but I think it
makes sense especially important if G
tx-94
and then f5 immediately this is a really
key idea I don't know if 95 then makes
any sense and it can maybe take and
immediately put some pressure on this d5
pawn the connective a bishop takes D
takes and then another Queen d5 also
however this position is extremely
weakened Jam flex position maybe this is
not a good idea at all yeah anyway he's
saving some time and it takes with the
bishop at least I haven't either wolf
now because going back makes no sense at
all
he fight is a very slow move actually
doubt that he can afford this okay so um
careful I can also play 95 gaining a
tempo here 95 is also a good move in
this position and it's nothing wrong
with castling either this is just a just
castle it's the kind of position where
every move is almost every book makes
sense and it's good 9595 walks in one
but probably any too careful and I think
he were very very lucky
also castle he can play Bishop a6 in
this position trying to trade his
slightly awkward bishop on b7 but I
really don't mind this at all I play
Luke c1 and as long as he again as he
has the pawn on c6 stuck on g6 as long
as this is the case blacks position
absolutely sucks
95s interesting okay so he tries to go
either f5y prepares Knight to d7 90 d7
especially would make quite some sense
and I think Knight e5 is the move that
is good yeah
just make sure that ninety seven is not
doing anything good
now I could just take that and play Roxy
one
yeah that's enough yeah okay as I can
take but but wait we were not so good I
might have other moves I'm thinking
about Queen h5 those kind of things
no is strategically fantastic actually
then you'll see one that I can almost
people devil maybe just think for a
moment if if something five on if
something like that is going to do
anything now I can really just take if I
45 I can just take then rope the AIDS I
can play interested Bishop move there's
nothing happening
yeah that's it's really good so if I get
the position on the board with 95 I mean
this is going to be a full-scale torture
absolutely torture
yeah this is the nightmare scenario for
the TTC for our structure you don't get
c5 in anymore and you are just sitting
on that call and the weak squares
especially a c5
yeah I wonder no no they have no real
opportunity to actually even play what I
was thinking I was thinking briefly and
move like c5 simply jettison a pawn to
open this up but I can play Bishop b5
and then things get completely completed
terrible
hmm now I don't see a move for black
rhodium
I wonder still yeah okay you can do that
the question is down so do I take it
that can actually understand in this
situation after Bishop takes rook takes
and black will probably take himself as
a five pawn is hanging and then actually
my whole my development is says some it
accelerated so loop FC one like Bishop
takes the three Queen takes rook c1
cuneiform it's got those two weaknesses
on c6 and a5 and I already see in
covering both okay look c8 creamy for a
six something stodgy like that you can
do so probably going to see four rather
right so we'll see eight cream c4 and
I'm willing upon now yeah
that wins the c64 narrating yeah Oh what
the heck no there's no real point to
that I can I can so this way he is going
to try to win this that's an interesting
idea
okay
so he tries to win today for pawn which
probably will be successful hmm it's an
interesting trial
yeah I mean there's not that much choice
I can play b3 but then you will take on
d4 and that isolated D point isn't all
that strong so we have to do this and
yeah I need I need some some look for
liking and then see what what to do
against this my rooks are active on the
C file the likelihood that I'm getting
some kind of ending where he has the two
pawns and cannot get real dangerous
passer in motion is probably quite high
if I can control further control the C
file potentially put it on the D file
and it's never going to make a pass on
them so I'm reasonably confident it's so
but that was a good defense he's gotten
rid of his weak cause he's a pawn down
now but all the pawns that he has are
healthy and in this in the case of the
true Queen side pawns even somewhat
threatening so I think that was a
reasonably good good try really so
creature a true
yeah he's attacking might be pawn and if
actually b3 is going to play a four I
guess
b3 a4 is completely forced b 3 a 4 5 si
- Queen B 3 Queen B 383 would be true
I'm getting this B pawn and I can
approach with the King room I wonder I
should be reading at at pages so let's
do this not invest much more time here
it looks like a very very good ending
maybe I'm seeing it wrong but I think it
should be pretty good and he almost has
to play for now I mean I don't quite see
how I can do it without I can also
actually after a 4 I can consider to
just take it and then play against the
b-pawn and I mean I am a lot quicker
than I have both looks and the Queen and
clay so let's say for B takes a for
group a for B five you cannot use any of
his looks and you cannot use they have a
book at all and that threaten to play
whoopsie - b1 and ultimately winning was
pong
that's an extra lesson that's not quite
sensible idea maybe
you
and yeah we'll see what he does the
eighth one is by far the most likely
move he's risking the the cleanest
potentially being trapped so so I'm
taking at him Luke 5 to see to was
possible that if he takes with the rook
now which seems most likely would be
five looks like just better for white
okay three Queen D one that's good for
once so I don't just don't think it's
got anything really great fun the b-pawn
cannot advance and group a three for
example there is going to be one
no I don't think I don't see anything
right important is that the rukon have
aid which is not playing at the moment
does not have any nem promising
promising target square well this is
just route b1 right what is he playing
with a1 then but it's not doing all that
much is it the one loop a one and take
it Queen takes but well that's actually
quite good I eat between f1 comes into
consideration Queen f1 if it takes
I just wind up upon and the only way to
cover it actually Queen should be one
now wait Queen Queen a3 Queen b1 no I
can't take Quincy form but now this is a
I think a decent technical move if he
moves the Queen if it if it trades it's
very easy I just win the b-pawn and if
he goes to any other square basically
like an okay 23 up like windy one but if
it goes to a four or a six or anything I
go Queen c4 and they just have one
attempt oh wait so clay then attacking
the b-pawn twice and winning it it's all
about them inactive rukon evade this
piece is doing absolutely nothing you
know
so Quincy for was the point was the idea
you can check me but this is just one
check I can just play Queen aside King
to g2 and I'm saying again you cannot
activate the hook you know that looks
very easy now now with two Ponzi and D
pawn on up given any ending pretty
easily the loop ending is easy and on
the Queen ending it's not a big deal
the Queen ending sometimes are tricky
because of the potential to petrels but
those additional pawns are they were
useful for covering the King so and
something to keep in mind
so sink down yeah both makes sense
actually this also makes a lot of sense
for Luke to be settled just keeping the
pressure on f7 all-new the rook has a
really good square on b7 so and what you
do here each for a screen G form not a
big deal
but I think I rather do this
so what is this doing don't see it
really some put the rock on the same
rank as it is as it was planned okay so
so I've got a really good control over
all of this maybe the Queen here on the
long diagonal having an eye on h5 and an
idea could be to simply to simply play
play the pawn up now this is also quite
helpful cover everything and now push
the pawn up the board yeah that's a good
way to improve the position maybe I
should have played Age 4 does you want
to go to f5 it's very lightly okay OS is
wondering like what happened so I just
resigned and yeah there was no
particular reason to resign especially
or particularly now it was a fairly lost
ending for for quite a while okay so
let's get and let's get into the and
then is this I hope I did not make any
substantial mistakes in all the rapid
games that I posted I don't think the
engine has yet found we really click big
blunder and then again let's see what
what it's saying about this Queen to d5
yeah it's a little bit of a of a
mysterious move in a way yeah I really
wonder the engine
likes my choice it even gives 25 in the
slight edge I mean I was thinking if I
do this and go here that and maybe I'm
with this threat that this may be a
little something here but I really
couldn't believe that that this position
gives anything tangible
I don't think so there should be seven
given by the comma something like this
you can maybe claim okay you will win
the rib we should pay homage I think we
need for is more interesting
okay be five and a queen a five oh
that's interesting
I did not think about this at all I was
just thinking Quigley Quigley won this
basically forced Queen b3 okay I may be
a turn Queen to a5 now that's not a very
natural move but it has a point yeah it
looks at d8 and after 93 is the queen
drops back you are ready to to take it
so so something like that is probably
quite a good position
yeah okay that would have been better
than but 21 is not a terrible choice if
I've given by the condom okay I would
that would have shocked me really
Wow so this isn't yes even that is not
equal
I know if I looks kind of weird like
here and then this that's simply better
for them kind of kind of amazed okay
this one yeah that's possible
interesting yeah if I would have been
whooping enterprising when here white is
better and the engine also mentions a
three and immediate capture yep night
December now one was maybe better this
and e3 is probably the cleanest solution
that can lead to the game of course
virgin
[Music]
now in the game it wasn't bad for my
first plate it wasn't bad should be
seven if it does that immediately
there are some tempo problems like in
been a force and now for the advantage
of development should give me at least a
slight edge mainly gimme I can really
manage than anymore
yeah I mean here G takes was was for
choice somehow and the Heller said I
think this wasn't anything special like
is finer now if I've spoiled this a lot
probably with maybe a four wasn't all
that precise and so on
yeah I mean if I a Highness really this
is wrong because if I do the luxury
where that kind of knew that you can
play if everything is fine already you
can also play a five but first of all
you have to see that you get to spawn
going maybe it's already too late as the
engine suggests I know that it only
gives zero point six but if you have to
play this you're in some trouble I mean
I frankly I don't believe it zero point
I know it goes up I know it goes up it
looks pretty terrible and threatening he
and I can take that looks bad
additionally f6 was a truly - event and
after a 5 it became very very tough
maybe you can play more incisively and
cathodes but this is just really really
bad 95 yeah here I mean what he did was
actually a pretty decent defense I
thought this was I mean it drops upon
ultimately but the computer wants to
play here this is this but this is this
is a whole load of rubbish what is wrong
with taking nothing first thinking is
there some kind of trick no this is this
this ending is pretty terrible I mean
it's not just the pawn it's also that
this is a real big pond construction I
don't know if that's really an
improvement unit yeah I mean I kind of
felt that this isn't such a bad idea
really yeah the engine wants to play d5
immediately push the pot yeah I don't
know I filmed this not a technically
good move
just make sure they're not mated so here
then v3 and after a 4-1 this is really a
favorable situation as you cannot push
the pond my idea is basically be 1 and
potentially Queen b3 just put everything
on that porn currently is playing
without the book and then the engine
agree is basically given your winning
position and Luke checks before ok huh
it's not a big difference as the b-pawn
gets lost anyway with something I could
have spotted
not really not from here unite and yeah
I don't know t6 I wonder play that again
with a 25 it's not the best move but
it's good enough I believe threatening
be sick so probably here and then this
having an eye on this threatening look
f6 now have like it's very soothing this
pretty pretty little name got no counter
play against the pawns okay guys thanks
for watching